mr. hora Kenyatta the president of Kenya
welcome to our team it's good to see you
here it's good to have you here thank
you for having us as far as I understand
your meeting with the Russian president
has just wrapped up ended you do realize
that before you he's met quite a few
leaders from Africa did you feel that is
he somewhat of a different man right now
is he a real friend of Africa I really
think so I don't think one would go
through all this effort if you weren't
serious about your engagement and you
must also not forget that for Russia if
we look at it in terms of the former
Soviet Union their engagement with
Africa stems all the way back from the
time of independence where this country
was a great supporter through all the
freedom movements so really this is not
is a rekindling and a refocused get
together well we're now focusing on
mutual prosperity we're focusing on
opportunities that exist in Africa for
mutual growth we're focusing on the
issues of security with terrorism and
issues of that nature focusing on new
technologies especially with regard to
digital technologies and so on and so
forth and I see a man very keen to
re-engage with Africa but with a much
clearer and much sharper focus now on
economics on security on defense and
issues that are more relevant to today's
world can you be a bit more specific
about what you as president of Kenya as
well as your nation what did you take
away from that meeting like I said I
took away a keen sense of interest not
just from the president
under government but even from the
business forums that have been conducted
there is a lot of interest by Russian
companies to establish themselves in
Africa in Kenya but a good number of
them already operating in Kenya and we
think that this is a result of this
forum we will have many more we're also
beginning to see an increase in interest
from a tourists who just looking at the
possibility of new destinations to take
their vacations we're also seeing an
increased engagement in terms of our
security relationships so definitely you
can see that we're moving and we're
heading in the right direction there's
an interesting pattern Mr Kenyatta
country's global powers that organized
similar events it seems that they tend
to not only compete but also in some
cases blame each other for not being
fair with Africa Donald Trump said that
Russia wants to exploit Africa just a
little earlier Vladimir we're not in in
an in an era where we are exploitable
and I think that's why we're here we
believe that we're out to work in the
world with partners with friends who are
interested in shared mutual prosperity
this is not the Africa of yesteryear we
as current leaders are leaders who are
focused on making good deals good deals
that are good for our country that are
good for our people but also with a
clear understanding that they must also
be good for the investors as well so we
are making friends across the globe we
are here making friends and establishing
partnerships with Russia
just like we will with the United States
with China with India
Africa is open for business and Africa
has huge and vast untapped potential and
I think that's why people are interested
in so I don't think anybody should
consider Africa they are domain Africa
belongs to the Africans we are welcoming
partners to come and join us in our
social economic development to take
advantage of the opportunities that
exist to take advantage of a massive
population if you put the African
population today you talk about one 2.2
billion people young people this is the
last opportunity for companies across
the globe so Africa is making friends
and we will not be limited that you
can't make friends here don't mean we
want to make friends with all those who
want to be friends with us who also want
to work with us who want to take
advantage of the opportunities that
exist for mutual benefits but just to
finish my thought if you don't mind that
mr. Putin also had some very strong
things to say about the former colonial
powers he even used the word
blackmailing so we're you strew do you
believe that all the parties here
genuinely want to be friends with Africa
and why is this blame game going on what
is it is this because I can't it's it's
just pure competition it's just pure
competition people competing for the
resources and opportunities that that
that exists and that is why I'm saying
we have left that colonial past behind
us and then the Putin is a hundred
percent correct but the colonial
relationships that we had were purely
extractive and not for the interest of
Africa or the Africa they were for
extractive basis to take advantage of
the resources of the continent to
develop the so-called then mother
countries Russia was instrumental in
helping Africa achieve her independence
objectives and now we're forging new
relations
new relations with Russia with all the
countries of the globe but based on
mutual prosperity we will not go back to
those days of yesteryear so the the
exploitation of the past is gone now
we're looking for viable workable
partnerships between us and the world
unfortunately I do have to mention some
of the issues that African the African
community is facing and according to the
Russian leader when he was speaking at
that roundtable he believes the most
difficult ones are terrorism the spread
of extremist ideology but he also
mentioned the Arab Spring which seems to
be in the past right now but the Russian
government believes that it's still a
reason for trouble on the continent
would you agree with that why do you
think mr. Foreman I do agree that
terrorism and extremism remains a threat
not just on the African continent but it
is a global threat and it is a threat
that we must face up to together we
cannot give in cannot allow terrorists
or extremists to take advantage and to
take control of the narrative this is
one area where we on the African
continent
with our partners in Russia and globally
have agreed that we must bring the
threat of terror and extremism to an end
because it destabilizes our ability to
achieve our development agenda with
reference to the Arab Spring I'm sure
what he was referring to which is true
is the destabilization that happened for
example in countries like Libya in
countries like Tunisia where once upon a
time there existed strong governments
well they may not have been perfect
governments but with that disruption you
found countries like Libya for example
collapsing and that vacuum unfortunately
was filled by some of these terror
groups who will now been causing havoc
in countries like mine countries like
Nigeria countries like Michel Jarre
because a lot of them using all the
weapons that they managed to collect and
turning this into instruments of
violence yeah not just in Libya but in
in in the surrounding countries as well
so definitely as far as North Africa is
concerned you could see that the
collapse of some of those regimes did
actually lead to greater instability not
just in the countries themselves but
beyond their boundaries and their
borders mr. president
staying with the topic of security we
also learned that Russia still has plans
to continue training the security
personnel in some cases military
personnel around Africa we know that the
Russian strategic bombers have flown
over to South Africa how do you see
Russia's role and involvement when it
comes to the security issues on the
continent well like I said they are
partners especially when we when you
talk Kenya especially with regard to the
war against terrorism
Russia has played a huge role in
supporting Amazon and Amazon operations
in Somalia or aimed at stabilizing
Somalia working together with troops
from neighboring countries and
like I have over said an even it's part
of our discussion today I did even worse
that father of asking President Putin to
encourage other countries to also come
on board and to be supportive of this
endeavor to rid ourselves of this menace
that is an enemy not only to life and
property but an enemy to through
development
Mr Kenyatta when it comes to the
economic side of it let's just go back
to that then we understand that perhaps
Russia still needs to do some catching
up if we compare the efforts that have
been made by Western countries in the
China
how much catching up does Russia have to
do and has it done a good job what's
your what what are your feelings about
that after this forum I I think as I
said when we started the interview I
think this is an excellent start it's an
excellent start on a plasti prosperity
where everything starts with the first
step it is true that for some time
Russia has sort of disengaged especially
commercially but we are now starting to
see more and more Russian companies
taking an interest in Africa
and and like I'm saying it's never -
it's never too late the issue is just
start once you start let's grow it from
that as I said Africa is open to
business with the world and we're happy
that Russia is taking up all role and
coming back onto the scene and
participating with us in our social
economic transformation
mr. president my last question maybe on
a bit of a lighter note have you managed
to see anything round Sachi have you
felt the warmth of the people and do you
have anything to say to the Russian I
can only say that it is the beautiful
City and I really wish I had just a bit
more time to to be to be to be out there
to mingle and I definitely plan to
return because I believe that people to
people connections are also equally
important just as much as we are looking
towards Russians coming to experience
Kenya to experience our culture to
experience our wildlife to experience
our beaches we would also want to see a
lot more Kenyans also coming out and
hopefully God willing with some good
time I plan to come back and spend some
time and enjoy the warmth and
hospitality of the people of Sochi and
the Russian people in general so I'm
looking forward to that sometime in the
future when time allows do you have any
special message for them for the Russian
people I think my message is that I
think there is tremendous potential
Africa will never forget the role that
the Russian people played in support of
our liberation struggles and movements
and mine is to say we're here to risa
meant to rebuild to rekindle those
partnerships to work together for mutual
for shared prosperity and growth and I
am really excited and looking forward at
opening these new boundaries that this
meeting has helped us to so I wish them
well I wish them luck and I look forward
to deepening our engagement at social
and cultural economic
level let's we strengthen and redefine
our relationship and move forward
together mr. president thank you very
much for your time especially after such
a busy day it's been wonderful to be
with you
thanks so much she's the best
you